all right we are all getting text
messages and flyers regarding our ballot
one piece of mail is especially
important if you want your vote to count
to eight news now investigator Vanessa
Murphy is here with what we need to know
Vanessa well you may have heard the term
signature curing if you mailed your
ballot you'll probably want to listen up
because right now Clark County is
reporting this affects more than 8 000
voters here if a signature on a mail
ballot cannot be verified or a ballot
isn't signed it needs to be cured Clark
County will reach out by phone or mail
with a letter like this and you can
either fill this out and mail it back it
has to be received by November 14th
though or you can respond via text or
online there's a list on Clark County's
website right now showing the names and
addresses of Voters whose signatures
need to be cured also for in-person
voting if you signed up to track your
ballot you may get a text from the
Secretary of State's office so for
example I voted early Friday this is
what I received it states you recently
cast a ballot in person at a polling
place if you did not contact the
elections office we know many voters
will be on high alert this election day
the Department of Justice announcing
Nevada is one of 24 states that will be
monitored to make sure Federal voting
rights laws will be followed complaints
can be made by phone or online we'll put
that information for you at 8newsnow.com
along with that list of signatures
needing to be cured tomorrow night I'll
be at the election headquarters in North
Las Vegas this is the hub for Clark
County we'll be talking with hopefully
some of our viewers and of course
observing the process back to you